Israeli media say Hamas and Israel are
open to talks on a new ceasefire and
exchange of captives and Prisoners the
report say Israel's intelligence Chief
has been given approval to initiate
talks with Qatari mediators negotiations
stalled at the beginning of this month
after a week-long ceasefire collapsed am
salute has more from occupied East
Jerusalem Israeli media is reporting
that the head of Israel's mosad David
Baria will travel to y Europe for the
second time in just under a week to meet
with qatar's prime minister and other
mediators to restart talks for
negotiations for the release of the
captives Israeli media is also
indicating that he will be joined by the
person who spearheading the intelligence
for the captives being held in Gaza this
comes after there was an indication that
the Israeli Prime Minister was perhaps
blocking this saying that military
pressure pressure was the only way to
bring back the captives when asked about
it in a press conference on Saturday he
deflected and said that the issue of the
captives is of the utmost importance to
the war cabinet and they are doing
everything they can to get them back but
the government has been under immense
pressure and the families of those
currently being held in Gaza have been
asking the Israelis to go back to the
negotiating table